who spent many many years as the voice
of the Sonics and he watched the former
Sonic's if you will go out last night in
that manner on behalf of the plays
arisen Damian Lillard he is Kevin
Calabro how are you Kevin good rich
thanks for having me what a game Oh Iver
I mean what do you think about when you
hear that back just less than 12 hours
it seems well it just reminds me the
great joy that we derived from sports
and why we follow sports and report on
sports and why we participate in sports
and and activities of this such and you
know to see 20,000 folks in this
community rise and celebrate with Damian
Lillard who's adopted this town as his
own you know a guy from Oakland
California who was not heavily recruited
went to Weber State was drafted by the
Blazers and folks said who and who has
just achieved just greatness I think not
only in the game of basketball but
certainly and just the way he has it
matured as an individual the lives that
he is touching this community I mean
it's just much more - Damian Lillard
than a game winner last night but boy
just really happy for him because on his
professional side he's a treat I think
he's achieved now since true greatness
and I think he's realized his destiny
which is to lead his team now in the
playoffs and get a little bit further
and before he gets all that I mean walk
me through your perspective we were you
right at that table where there was that
pig pile afterwards where were you
physically for that were you right there
we were right we were right across from
all of that going on and the guy that
set next to us was use of Newark itch
and that's what people should remember
is that they're starting five man use of
Newark itch of course is not in this
series and he broke his leg about a
month ago and he decided midway through
the third quarter that his team needed
and he got dressed at his home in the
suburbs drove in and got there with
about five minutes left and made a
Willis read like appearance on the bench
and it just seemed to ignite the
basketball team they were down 15 points
in the fourth quarter rich so Newark is
set next to us is and came over and set
next to us is all that was unfolding he
wanted to stay away from all of that
activity obviously was a broken leg but
all of that was go
in front of us it was magnificent Damien
was over there with his family it was
high-fiving the crowd he was being
mobbed by his teammates it was something
to behold yeah I mean you would know
this because was that his brother who
ran out on the court it was that his
ministers there is mom and dad were
there as granddad was there I mean the
whole family there sitting front row it
was just oh if this was destined to be
that's his hope that was his whole
family running out but he did it in
front of generations of Lillard Zoey
you're saying they were all there they
were all there
it was you know his agents there after
the game and you know his whole
entourage there it was it was fabulous I
just can't think of a just a better
scenario for he and his family in this
community and then just one more on the
moment here see Kevin Calabro
from the Blazers network at Trail
Blazers television play-by-play
announcer here on the Rich Eisen show so
you're watching this unfold and it's
just it's becoming apparent he's gonna
take the shot
I mean it's becoming apparent he's not
only to take the shot he's not gonna
drive the basket he's gonna shoot I mean
what was that like from your perspective
as you're as you're real time trying to
describe the action there Kevin well we
know that he is he's good from the logo
he's a logo Lillard you know they got
that tag earlier this year and he has
already hit Oklahoma City with a fifty
one point effort back in March when he
didn't shoot the three well but he was
something like 18 to 20 from the
free-throw line this guy is one of the
superior shooters in the league 10th in
the league and in scoring you could make
a case that he could be the leading
scorer in this league or top three if
that's what he wanted to do but you just
knew he was going to take that final
shots
fly ball game you've got an opportunity
here he's already risen up he's 10 of 18
from 30 feet or better already in the
series we know that we've seen it fit
the course of the year make these big
shots from long-range ends up for six
from 30 feet plus in Game five when he
let it go to be there was just there was
no surprise there was no show
he had an open shot and in my opinion
he's a lot like Steph Curry James Harden
and in that regard and you look at the
numbers and they bear that out this year
from from 28 feet or better those three
guys are El supremo he clears midcourt
clears the timeline he is within range
because he has confidence strength
remember he played 45 minutes in this
game and he scored 34 in the first half
he had to carry him in the first half
and McCollum picked up his third foul
just nine minutes into his shift in the
first quarter and he led the Blazers
with 45 plus minutes of play this is a
guy that average is close to 35 and a
half minutes a ball game in the NBA
played 80 games this year I mean that
just speaks to the strength of this kid
that he still had something left in the
tank you just pull up and take that shot
over one of the toughest thunders in the
league
Bulger it's just yeah yeah and Paul
George saying it was a bad shot to which
which which Lillard reached yea which
which Lillard retweeted that tweet with
that quote with an lol I mean he's
having he just instagrammed out a sunsoo
quote about biding your time and the one
who wins is usually the one who's quiet
and holds his tongue I mean it really is
it really is a remarkable you know for
lack of a better phrase up yours and and
cold dish serving in each in a series
just for this moment obviously but with
the Blazers struggles over the last two
years to win a single playoff game and
for him to do it in this manner against
a team that used to come from the
Pacific Northwest and I want to get on a
little bit on that with you Kevin
further your history of calling Sonic's
games and and the history of you calling
games as long as you have I said the
only thing you could equate this to and
it might even top was Jordan's shot over
ello an 89 to wrap up that first round
series I wonder what you think well it
was certainly shocking and and the
import of it is you know obviously is
felt here in the area because they had
lost 10 consecutive playoff games coming
into the series they had lost 10 and
burrow on the road in playoff series and
so to shake all of that certainly it was
big and
you know unburden themselves of that in
this series against the Thunder I you
know I'm just thinking back at some of
the spectacular efforts we've seen in
the Pacific Northwest with the Sonics
and you know going from Gary Payton
Shawn Kemp devil shrimp Sam Perkins that
group in the mid nineties and then later
just before their demise and the move
out of town remember Ray Allen had some
phenomenal years with the Sonics he was
five years with the Sonics and you know
I Payton and again should say Lillard in
no way reminds me at all and Gary Payton
blasters in comparison site you know the
way I look at Lillard is he's a lot like
Tim Hardaway and his prime before the
knee injury the great handle the
crossover the ability to shoot the three
the strength the upper-body strength
just his his body he's got the driving
instinct of a Derrick Rose in his prime
when they had MVP or 2010 when get to
the rim just kind of defies gravity
hangs and contorts at the glass he's so
good at that Lillard he's just
phenomenal playing off contact and
getting to the rim and then the kind of
accountants on the elegance if you will
of Ray Allen and that radar ability to
kind of sense the moment with the great
poise and the countenance and that like
you said that that serenity that he has
on the floor and the other thing about
Lillard is he follows boxing he loves
box I don't care what kind of obscure
boxing match you're talking about
Lillard will know who's involved what's
at stake who's good who's bad in the
ring that's the other thing he works out
during the offseason he's a boxer in the
offseason that's one of his top physical
regimens in getting himself ready for
the season is to get in and spar and box
and work on the speed bag work on the
footwork in the hands and the whole
thing and the focus and so he approaches
the game like a boxer as well I mean
it's really something to see him get
ready for the game he's Lowe's classic
first guy in the gym last guy to leave
type guys and so there's no wonder that
he excels at this level but to compare
last night's performance is something
I've seen in the past I really can't I
mean I bet that was the
one of the single most greatest
performances I have seen in professional
basketball that's saying a lot man that
is I mean it really was something to see
and something to watch so I guess last
one for you Kevin is there still some
animus in the Pacific Northwest towards
Oklahoma City or is that just so long
ago now that it's it's um it's just
water under the bridge I'm wondering you
know to give voice to all that well I
think that there is certainly in Seattle
and there's always the hope that NBA
basketball will you know return to
Seattle there are a number of basketball
fans in Seattle that view comes out here
to Portland is about a three-hour drive
about 150 miles and a number of season
ticket holders here in Portland are from
Seattle will come down and share its
season ticket package as well so there's
certainly an element of green and gold
that you see it every blazer ballgame
mixed in with the red and black so I
think there have been a number of fans
in Seattle that have embraced the
Blazers as sort of as their their their
NBA fix if you will and I still think
there are some misgivings certainly in
Seattle about the way that things went
down you know spend 10 years now going
on 11 that the Sonics left and you know
41 years of history a world championship
a number of Hall of Famers including the
Jack the great Jack Sikma just this past
spring Lenny Wilkens still lives in the
area Gary Payton the Hall of Famers
still lives or works in Seattle and we
see Shawn Kemp all the time they're dead
love shrimp I mean they're there any
number of Sonic's and still live in the
area so it's it is a little bit
bittersweet I guess yeah when you when
you see Oklahoma City playing they're a
bit you know they have their own
identity now and you know what's what's
transpired is transpired and there's
nothing you can do about that now and
hopefully that NBA will come back to
Seattle at some point well great call
Kevin it really was that's why I wanted
to pick up the phone and just chat with
you and because I felt it I I felt it
obviously through your voice and just
through this
just seeing the folks in the crowd go
absolutely nuts to see a 37 footer over
the guy who dunked with no time left to
can against them to cap the revenge with
a 50-point night with no time left I
mean you just really can't script it it
was amazing it was just amazing it was
it was surely a pleasure to be a part of
I really feel blessed to be able to sit
there and observe and report for the
fans it was terrific Kevin thanks for
the call appreciate it we'll chat down
the line thanks rich talk to you man you
got it
Kevin Calabro for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app